الرياض تكرم صوت الارض نادين نسيب نجيم
تفتح صفحه جديده في حياتها و عمرو دياب
وتامر حسني معا لاول مره اليكم الابرز
الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
يا خبريني عنا جرى
خبرني كرامه رياضه الاسبوع الماضي ذكرى
المطرب الملحن السعوديه الراحل طلال مداح
الملقب بصوت الارض في حدث موسيقيا ضخم
حظيه بتفاعل كبير
[موسيقى]
وشارك في ليله صوت الارض 43 فنانه وفنانا
عربيا من السعوديه والخليج وسوريا ولبنان
والاردن ومصر وتونس والمغرب انشد فيها
محمد عبده ونخبه من نجوم الغناء العرب
اشهر اغاني مداح
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وكرم تركي ال الشيخ رئيس مجلس اداره
الهيئه العامه للترفيه في السعوديه عائله
الفنان الراحل معلنا اطلاق اسمه على اكبر
استوديو تسجيل موسيقي في الشرق الاوسط
وامتدت ليله صوت الارض قرابه الخمس ساعات
وشارك فيها نجوم المنتخب السعودي لكره
القدم الذين فازوا بلقب كاس اسيا لاول مره
في تاريخهم سنه
1984 وعزف فيها الفنان السعودي عبادي
الجوهر على اله العود الخاصه بالراحل طلال
مداح والتي احتفظ فيها بعد وفاته على خشبه
المسرح في العام 2000
واختمت الليله باستحضار مؤثر لصوره الفنان
الراحل بتقنيه الهولوجرام منشدا الى جانب
محمد عبده قلبي تولع بالرياض
[موسيقى]
عن الوصف اللسان
وفي السعوديه ايضا احتفل نادي النصر
السعودي بعيد ميلاد نجمه كريستيانو
رونالدو الذي سجل اول اهدافه في الدوري
السعودي مع فريقه الجديد الاسبوع الماضي
كما هن منتخب البرتغال هدفه التاريخي
رونالدو بعيد ميلاده الثامن
[موسيقى]
وفي عيد ميلادها حظيت نادين نسيب نجيم
بلحظات رومانسيه قدم فيها حبيبها عرض
الزواج النجمه اللبنانيه وسط احتفاء
الحاضرين لتعلن لاحقا خبر خطوبتها رسميا
الذي حقق تفاعلا كبيرا على منصات التواصل
في العالم العربي
وفي مصر تداول الرواد منصات التواصل على
نطاق واسع فيديو لغناء النجمين المصريين
عمرو دياب وتامر حسني معا لاول مره وذلك
في زفاف الفنان ومصمم المؤثرات البصريه
وعروض الالعاب الناريه احمد عصام الذي
حضره نخبه من نجوم الفن المصريين
واخيرا افتتح مهرجان الاقصر للسينما
الافريقيه فعاليات دورته الثانيه عشره
التي تستمر الى التاسع من شهر شباط فبراير
الجاري وكرم المهرجان في حفل الافتتاح
الفنانين المصريين محمد رمضان وهاله صدقي
واخرين